freunde der allerletzten wir müssen
irgendwie auf die 1800 2504 sind bei
1600 hallo mein name ist klug und wir
spielen heute das spiel topleague
anywhere tube
das war laut click to stay up das heißt
wir müssen wir müssen über diese teile
ich weiß nicht was passiert denn ich
muss habe ich leben oder wiso mein gott
freunde es wird immer schneller
es wird immer schneller wir sind die
ganze zeit immer schneller oder bilde
ich mir das nur ein um ein gott
es wird viel schneller freunde was ist
denn das meine augen tun weh
das ist viel zu stellt für diese welt
aber ich bin tatsächlich eigentlich ganz
gut ich bin noch nie so wahrscheinlich
wie soll ich das denn so schnell
schaffen man wie krass schnell ist das
denn ich weiß gar nicht worauf mich
meine augen konzentrieren sollen das ist
einfach nur ich weiß nicht ob das bei
youtube so rüberkommt und warum nicht
auch so schnell kommentiere aber meinen
augen tun einfach unfassbar weh oh mein
gott oh hab ich auch schmerzen 698
versuch das mal zu knacken aber wir
versuchen natürlich direkt nochmal das
ist echt noch so easy am anfang und
gleich denke ich mir einfach wieder
know-how grips alter was geht was geht
das ist schon wieder so unfassbar
schnell ich habe das gefühl immer wenn
ich an diesem langen teilen vorbei komme
dass ich dann nochmal ein stückchen
schneller
ich hab's langsam raus man geht immer
zurückgesetzt und zwar immer wenn jetzt
gerade ist der gelbe hier komme ich
stecke jetzt mal ein stückchen weiter
links ist ein stück weiter links wenn
ich jetzt wieder sterben ist er komplett
links und jetzt bin ich komplett tot
das heißt ich habe quasi so fünf leben
okay das ist leben nummer eins das leben
nummer zwei leben nummer drei leben
nummer vier und das letzte lebensjahr 5
ich habe fünf leben und das ist glaube
ich der schlechteste score dem an diesem
spiel haben kann ich will nur einmal die
700 schaffen weil ich ja vorhin 698
hatte da haben meine augen schon so mega
krass wehgetan aber da konnte ich das
spiel noch nicht so risikoalter was geht
denn bei diesem spiel ab man es so
schnell war mir glaube ich echt uni wir
sind schon längst über die 700 weg das
ist gar kein problem für mich gar kein
ding für den king aber das ist halt
gerade einfach nur noch unfassbar für
meine augen das tut einfach wirklich nur
noch meine augen
es tut so weh oh mein gott ich weiß
nicht ob es beim zuschauen weh tut aber
bei mir gerade alter meine augen setzen
auseinander
hier sieht man das irgendwie ich habe
das gefühl meine augen zittern von links
nach rechts meine fresse aber egal
freundin wird versuchen natürlich direkt
normal und zwar war vorhin unser heißt
1302 das jetzt schon langsam im
vergleich zu gerade ist es immer richtig
traurig wenn man diese langen teile
sieht weil man weiß dass das ganze noch
ein stückchen schneller wird und die
augen ein noch mehr zerbersten werden
wahr
wir werden schon die ganze zeit wieder
schneller freunde übrigens heute
ich bin gestorben ich wollte sagen dass
heute ein toller tag ist und zwar habe
ich meine wenn ich etwas tolles sagen
werde wollte ich sterbe
dazu mache ich hier ich wollte sagen
dass heute ein toller tag ist weil ich
gerade meine jetzige wohnung in der ich
hier gerade drin bin nicht verkauft habe
weil sie gehörte ja nicht mehr habe ich
sie weiter vermietet das heißt jetzt in
den nächsten tagen ich weiß gar nicht
mehr nachkam vorproduzieren vielleicht
bin ich schon umgezogen ich bin ich
mache das nicht direkt zu öffentlich
deswegen hat es wahrscheinlich nicht
direkt mitbekommen andere youtuber film
dann ihren umzug und mal alles möglich
aber ich bin wahrscheinlich schon
umgezogen wenn ihr das video erzählt das
soll jetzt auch nicht negativ sein gegen
welche youtuber die dungeon tools machen
und was weiß ich nicht bin nicht so dass
nun nicht bewirbt ich bin halt nicht so
der fan von diesem spiel weil es meine
augen komplett auseinander nimmt alter
das ist nicht wahr wieso ist denn das
hier schon wieder so schnell ich bin
schon wieder gestorben freunde das
könnte tatsächlich grad neuer highscore
werden ich habe noch zwei leben und ich
bin gerade mal bei 1000 irgendwas ich
glaube wir müssen diesmal wirklich
tatsächlich über die 1300 was wir unser
genauer highscore ich glaube das war
1332 oder so und wir sind jetzt schon
bei der 1300 und haben jetzt schon den
900 das leben konzentrieren den kopf von
lukas lang ebt von pankow mein gott oh
mein gott oh mein gott es ist so schnell
und meine augen sieht schon weh und ich
will ihn nicht verlieren
denn ich singe denn singen ist gut immer
werden lukas ist sehr guten spielen dass
die kanal grad nochmal bezeugen denn wir
sind gestorben gerade was ich sagen
wollte ich bin nicht jemand der das
direkt öffentlich macht mit der wohnung
und so weil ich bin einer der
hauptgründe warum ich ausgezogen bin war
das ein brief von einer zuschauerin vor
der tür lag war als nicht so cool
deswegen mache ich da auch keine room to
oder so ich werde natürlich bilder aus
der wohnung post gewerteten neuen
hintergrund sehen vielleicht zeigt sich
dass mit aufnahme zimmer dann aber keine
großartigen room to oder informationen
ich sag euch auch nicht welcher stadt
ich wohne es ist nicht die stadt ihr
denkt 'oh mein gott meine augen wenn ich
dieses spiel spiele ich sollte offen zu
sehen aber ich wollte sagen dass ein
letzter versuch in aller letzter versuch
ich werde mich jetzt so krass
konzentrieren dass es einfach nur neue
high zu werden kann ich bin mir zwar
nicht sicher was unser alter war aber
wenn der neue high score steht dann bin
ich auf jeden fall glücklich hier
schneller
ich bin gestorben man ihr dürft nicht
ablenken alter hut auf
einfach klatschen und luca glückwünschen
ok danke da seid ihr auf 55 es nicht und
wir singen
luca
wir haben die 1000 geknackt und wir sind
auf dem weg zu den neuen high score nps
war ist unser highscore irgendwie 1800
ich bin mir zwar nicht sicher was genau
ist aber das ist jetzt auch schon sehr
letztes leben alter wir müssen jetzt
mehr als 600 schaffen ok freunde das ist
der allerletzte waren wenn mich jetzt
nicht mehr als 600 schafen freunde der
haller lässt er an wir müssen irgendwie
auch die 1800 bis 2500 wir sind bei 1600
wir sind bei 1000